you know i'd like to start with um what
is the product
that you are trying to create in the
world or products
and why is that important to you yeah i
mean it has been a pretty
pretty crazy incredible ride getting
here we we were we were private for um
you know for a few years
and a lot of people ask you know why did
you go public well mainly it was because
of we work
once wework came around they kind of
there's a big glass house the cracks
started coming the whole thing fell down
overnight
and you know they wanted to they wanted
to see our entire business model
when investors prior to wework investors
would come and invest a lot of money and
it was you just
should sell them on the vision that
they'd hire mckinsey to analyze your
business and
they'd get the sign off and they'd make
the investment once wework came along
ultimately the next question was what
makes you not the next we work
so the discussion totally changed and it
became a problem
so we wanted to uh we wanted to show
everyone when you when you go public you
you show them
everything you they get us here books
the money every contract every related
party transaction
they get to see everything and
ultimately what that is it brought a lot
of confidence to the investors around
nicola
so what is nikola we are a zero emission
original equipment manufacturer building
very big
zero emissions semi trucks but i would
tell everyone we're not really just a
truck builder we're actually a
technology infrastructure play and then
why is that it's because we don't make
money necessarily on the trucks we make
money on the on the infrastructure the
hydrogen
so if you think about a diesel truck
when you buy a diesel right now it's a
brand new peterbilt you know big semi
truck
you're gonna pay 150 000 for the date
for the diesel truck and you'll pay
about a million dollars
ish uh for the for the fuel for that
truck
so the big problem with that is the oil
companies make all the money
so we came in we said look we want to
take all that money from the oil
companies bring it into nicola
and when you buy our truck we cover the
cost of your truck your service your
warranty your maintenance
and your hydrogen hydrogen fuel costs
and so now someone just pays us per mile
to drive it that's it they never have to
worry about any other variable
and we've been incredibly successful
over 10 billion dollars in pre-order
reservations
an 800 million dollar order with anaheim
bush 13 routes coming for their
distribution centers we're using our
trucks and our
our business model and uh you know we've
had a wild ride i mean we own public and
uh
you know it's a it's been a wild ride
it's very difficult being public i'll be
honest very
difficult but we got a lot of great
things ahead of us and uh that's always
fun to see
yeah and so this is what makes it a
challenging i think interview is because
there's so much to talk about here just
pausing for one second on something you
said in terms of your inspiration
wework was instructive to you because
they had closed opaque books for such a
long time
that their problems festered until the
point that they became existential and
killed the company
essentially and your position is hey if
that company had been public earlier
all of that sunlight would have come in
and disinfected everything and they
would not have been involved in such
crazy shenanigans correct am i summing
that up
you could not have summed that up better
honestly that he had they had so much
control over there that it was
unhealthy and so people people even ask
me they said hey why are you not the ceo
anymore
why are you the executive chairman and
why are you you know you're the founder
and it's for that exact reason so that i
didn't want
that much control it's uh it's unhealthy
for an organization to have a dictator
and so what i i'm the executive chairman
the ceo reports to me
but there is a very qualified great
friend of mine who's
his name's mark russell he was the
president of a publicly traded
company called worthington industries
and he's our ceo now and so what that
does it allows you to have more than one
voice in the boardroom allows you to
have more than one opinion
you're not drinking your own kool-aid